docker a tool that can package software
into containers that run reliably in any
environment but what is a container and
why do you need one let's imagine you
built an app with cobalt that runs on
some weird flavor of linux you want to
share this app with your friend but he
has an entirely different system so the
problem becomes how do we replicate the
environment our software needs on any
machine one way to package an app is
with a virtual machine where the
hardware is simulated then installed
with the required os and dependencies
this allows us to run multiple apps on
the same infrastructure however because
each vm
is running its own operating system they
tend to be bulky and slow
now a docker container is conceptually
very similar to a vm
with one key difference instead of
virtualizing hardware containers only
virtualize the os
or in other words all apps or containers
are run by a single kernel
and this makes almost everything faster
and more efficient there are three
fundamental elements in the universe of
docker
the docker file the image and the
container the docker file is like dna
it's just code that tells docker how to
build an image which itself is a
snapshot of your software
along with all of its dependencies down
to the operating system level the image
is immutable and it can be used to spin
up multiple containers which is your
actual software running in the real
world
create a docker file and use from to
start from an existing template like
ubuntu this base image gets pulled down
from the cloud
and you can also upload your own images
to a variety of different docker
registries
from there you might want to use run to
run a terminal command that installs
dependencies into your image
you can set environment variables and do
all kinds of other stuff then the last
thing you'll do is set a default command
that's executed when you start up a
container
and now we can create the image file by
running the docker build command
it goes through each step in our docker
file to build the image layer by layer
we can then bring this image to life as
a container with the docker run command
as your app demands more resources you
can run it on multiple machines multiple
clouds on-prem
or wherever you want reliably this has
been docker in 100 seconds
if you enjoyed it make sure to like and
subscribe and stay tuned for more docker
content coming to this channel soon
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one